hey Hulu fans I'm Carrie Washington and
I would be honored and delighted if you
watched my new comedy unprisoned my
character page is a marriage and family
therapist raising her 16 year old son on
her own until her father is released
from prison and moves in with her ah
it's heartfelt it's funny and it
highlights the story of millions of
Americans experiencing similar
situations so please don't miss
unprisoned on Hulu and stick around to
see what else is premiering this month
getting out of prison well there's
somebody at the door hey baby girl I was
always there for you if I always you
mean this call is from a federal prison
you don't even give him a chance I've
seen this movie and I Know How It Ends
I'm
trying I think I'm starting to see that
good gravy is Harriet Tubman the
inventor of the bathtub
uh-huh oh hello who is this it's your
mama
Jack I think I found something three
women were strangled over the last two
weeks you're on the lifestyle desk
you're not covering a homicide I think
the murders are connected we had them we
just let them walk away you really want
to use this paper to tear down the
police department I need you to call in
a favor
the Russian capitalists and an American
Communists on a 250 million dollar
luxury
[Music]
going hungry
[Applause]
this is really really bad
it could be anyone we're gonna tear this
city apart
there's this guy that lives across the
street and he's always looking over here
staring right at me what's happening we
found a woman murdered in her apartment
yeah
he's been following me
you deaf clean that lab you get out you
may think that thing looks human it's an
animal just keeping it tight
this creature is capable of
understanding emotions when he looks at
me he doesn't know how I am incomplete
get him out what are you talking about I
I can either save him or let him die how
many people know what it's like to be us
right now I want my life to mean
something I don't want to hate life I
want to embrace what's next
of new participants daily from this
world to the next once you're in a state
of passing we terminate your physical
form in three two one
wait I can't make it stop you can stop I
need you
poor man took me as a hostage
okay having a bad week why don't you let
me buy you a drink if I think anything
might happen to her I'm gonna kill both
of you
are you in love with me yes hopefully
get jammed up or even caught on the
street
I just want you to know that you're
going to die in federal prison
Frank Costello Mr sober after
you won't be paid as a regular car but
there's a bonus involved
so what do I do you will not ever know
the identity of undercover people you
have anyone in with Costello presently
maybe do you know who I am maybe not we
got a cop and my crew sooner lady's
gonna find out who I am and he's gonna
kill me
it's not so hard to build an Empire
but whatever happens next
it is here
her death is part of a pattern another
missing murdered indigenous woman this
is a very broken
it's about corruption
truth matters
90s was about power Anthony pelicano is
getting hired by rich people to solve
high-level problems there were rumors
that pelicano have been wiretapping
people just stick with me baby I'll take
care of it Anthony pelicano is going to
go down the question is who else is
going to go down with him people say
that there are no seasons in Los Angeles
think of it as your average windy night
how bad can it be
are you ready
to go cap
on the farm I don't need girls I have
dated a lot of guys in the city it
hasn't worked out for me I love
everything about him
[Music]
it would mean a lot